vous êtes nombreux aujourd'hui à vous
engager pour construire un monde plus
durable
vous êtes nombreux à mettre de l'énergie
dans des projets de transition
énergétique de préservation de la
biodiversité de nouveaux modèles
d'éducation mais je vous pose cette
question est ce que nous pouvons
construire demain avec des outils du
siècle passé
nous avons fait un premier pas vers un
nouveau paradigme vers une nouvelle
façon de voir le monde
nous quittons peu à peu le monde de la
compétition pour tenter et tester la
collaboration mais comment allons-nous
garder cette posture assumée cette
vision si nous continuons de nous
appuyer sur deux des outils principaux
sans nous permettre de les remettre en
question je veux parler de l'argent et
plus précisément de la création
monétaire un sujet dont on parle très
rarement parce qu'ils restent obscurs
parfois même pour les banquiers
et puis de nos systèmes d'organisation
qui sont encore trop souvent
hiérarchique et dont on mesure les
limites mais pour lesquels on peine à
trouver des solutions
alors pour ça pour vous parler de ça je
voudrais prendre à l'image d'un moteur
l'argent c'est son carburant l'énergie
extérieur qui lui permet de fonctionner
et puis le modèle d'organisation et bien
c'est son rendement
son énergie intérieure et je vais
commencer par vous parler de l'argent
puisque à titre personnel j'ai décidé
pour agir de m'engager dans le farinet
le projet de monnaies locales et
complémentaires en valais m'engager dans
ce projet m'a amené à me plonger dans
près de 5000 ans d'histoire a étudié de
nombreuses alternatives économiques
qu'elle soit contemporaine ou plus
anciennes
nous projetons tous quelque chose de
particulier sur l'argent que ce soit la
réussite le pouvoir
la sécurité ou même le plaisir
mais au-delà de ces considérations
l'argent reste un formidable outil qui
nous permet de disposer des ressources
physiques et humaines qui nous permet de
mener à bien nos projets dans ma
carrière j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler dans des environnements très
variés dans certains d'entre eux il
semble que l'argent coule à flots je
pense à à la banque
je pense au consulting nom marketing et
à la communication
et puis dans d'autres il était
cruellement défaut l'art la création la
petite start up médical le monde
associatif
alors mon premier constat est bien c'est
que ce carburant est très
inéquitablement répartie
vous avez sûrement tous déjà vu ces
graphiques qui représente la répartition
des richesses dans le monde et on
comprend aisément que ceux qui possèdent
tout cet argent ont comme principal
intérêt à faire perdurer le système qui
leur a permis de s'enrichir qu'ils vont
investir toujours cet argent
essentiellement dans les domaines qui
leur a permis qui leur a permis
d'accumuler leur fortune lorsque un
milliardaire un maniaque de
l'informatique par exemple décide
d'engager des millions pour la recherche
la promotion et le développement des ogm
il décide seul sans contrôle
démocratique de l'avenir de
l'agriculture
alors que d'autres petits projets qui
cherche à développer un monde plus
équitable où il fait bon vivre pour tout
le monde donc souvent cruellement de ce
précieux carburant pour démarrer
ensuite si on étudie un petit peu
l'histoire de la monnaie eh bien on se
rend compte qu'elle a souvent été un
outil de pouvoir et de domination
à l'époque médiévale par exemple c'était
le souverain qui créent la monnaie pour
payer ses soldats les commerçants les
marchands les producteurs avaient
l'obligation de l'accepter
et pour être sûr qu'ils le faisaient et
bien une partie lors été prélevés sous
la forme d'un impôt la manette est donc
un moyen pour le souverain de
ponctionner les producteurs en échange
d'une protection contre un autre
souverain et une autre armée qui
pratiquait la même technique
nous avons donc identifier les les deux
principales problématiques associées à
la monnaie c'est le pouvoir qui est
générée par l'accumulation de la
richesse et le pouvoir qui est générée
par la création monétaire elle même
alors à travers sa version actuelle le
farinet ne vient pas révolutionner le
monde de l'économie mais de nombreux
mécanismes qui ont été créées par les
monnaies locales et complémentaires
cherche à résoudre ces problématiques et
il n'est pas exclu que dans l'avenir
nous décidions de les incorporer à notre
modèle par exemple une monnaie fondante
une monnaie fondante qu'on soit qu'une
dette finit toujours par s'éteindre
elle le fait en faisant fondre les
capitaux accumulés autant que les dettes
dans le temps ça pour avantage de donner
la même capacité de création monétaire à
toutes les générations qu'elle soit
passée présentes ou futures
alors un tel système nous interroge
notamment par rapport à notre système de
prévoyance qui est basé sur
l'accumulation mai
et ça peut en choquer certains d'entre
vous mais c'est exactement ce qu'on vit
actuellement avec les tours négatif qui
nous sont imposées par les banques
centrales qui viennent et rodez jour
après jour les capitaux stockés à la bns
la grande différence réside dans ce qui
est fait de l'argent qui a fondu dans le
cadre de la bns eh bien il disparaît
simplement alors que dans des modèles
comme le chiemgauer en allemagne un
billet papier qu'il faut réactiver
régulièrement en collant des petites
vignettes dessus et bien dans ce cas là
ce qui est récupéré ce qui a fondu et
réinjectés dans des projets associatifs
locaux le crédit mutualisé est un autre
outil qui est à l'origine de la création
du veer
en 1934 il décentralise la création
monétaire pour la confier à tous les
citoyens ou tout au moins à tous les
membres du réseau
chacun a alors la possibilité de créer
une certaine quantité de monnaie et de
l'investir dans les échanges qui lui
semble important c'est une autre façon
de concevoir l'engagement citoyen où
l'on ne se contente pas de voter ou bien
d'élire quelqu'un pour nous représenter
mais où chaque échange chaque acte
d'achat devient un engagement vers le
monde que l'on souhaite mettre en place
ces mécaniques nécessitant un shift une
transformation dans notre vision est
dans notre façon de voir le monde pour
confier la création monétaire à tous
plutôt qu'un petit groupe
eh bien il faut avoir confiance en nos
semblables pour accepter que les dettes
s'éteignent et bien il faut avoir un
profond besoin d' équité
il faut passer de logique de compétition
à une logique de collaboration mais
comment pourrions-nous pensée
collaboration alors que depuis toujours
nous baignons dans une atmosphère
compétitive que ce soit à l'école que ce
soit dans nos emplois que ce soit dans
les exemples qui nous sont véhiculés par
les médias
il semble que c'est toujours le fort qui
l'emportent sur le faible et même qui
l'emportent sur finalement tous les
autres camps dans notre éducation avons
nous appris à collaborer quels outils
nous ont été transmis pour le faire ça
m'amène à mon deuxième point celui du
rendement du moteur
il semblerait qu'aujourd'hui nos
rendements sont au plus bas alors je ne
parle pas de la productivité la
productivité elle a été boosté par
l'arrivée de l'informatique par
l'automatisation
non je parle de l'engagement de chacun
d'entre nous dans nos entreprises et nos
organisations
une étude de l'institut galope aux états
unis schématise l'engagement dans les
entreprises à travers l'image du bateau
si une dizaine de personnes embarquent
et bien trois vont ramer vers l'avant 5
vont frapper dans l'eau pour générer
quelques accrocs est tabou sur et donner
l'impression qu'ils travaillent et 2
vont même ramené en arrière et tout ce
qu'on a trouvée pour essayer d'accélérer
ce bateau est bien c'est de mettre les
rameurs en compétition les uns avec les
autres
ça provoque de nombreux surchauffe qu'on
appelle aussi des burnout
alors moi ce que je crois et bien c'est
qu'on devrait plutôt prendre conscience
de notre solidarité notre seule et
d'hériter pas au sens où on l'entend
habituellement qui consiste à laisser
mourir personne en lui donnant le
minimum vital
non notre solidarité dans le sens où
nous sommes solidaires
les uns des autres à l'image des roues
dentées dans un moteur ensemble elles
travaillent et collaborent pour
permettre au moteur de fournir de
l'énergie mécanique à l'intérieur du
bloc
chaque pièce pistons tuyaux bougies et
différentes l'une de l'autre
chacune a son utilité mais toutes
ensemble elles interagissent pour
permettre d'atteindre un but final et je
pense que comme humain et bien c'est à
ça aussi que nous devrions être appelé
mais encore faudrait-il avoir la vision
de ce que nous sommes appelés à
construire ensemble alors à plus petite
échelle
eh bien c'est ce que nous avons essayé
de faire autour du projet du farinet
ensemble comme groupe
nous avons pris le temps d'établir une
vision et une mission nous connaissons
un 6e tous plus grands vers lequel notre
collaborateur notre participation va
permettre d'arriver
nous allons pris tout le travail qu'ils
avaient à faire et nous l'avons coupée
en un certain nombre de rôles à l'image
des roues dentées chacun différents
chacun avec son utilité mais tous en
interaction les uns avec les autres et
pour ne pas étouffer la créativité des
gens eh bien nous ne les avons pas
défini avec une liste de tâches à faire
non nous avons nous les avons exprimé
sous la forme d'un potentiel à réaliser
d'un but à atteindre
parce que finalement qu'importe le
chemin choisi pourvu que la fonction
soit remplir ce type d'organisation
s'appuie beaucoup sur l'autonomie et la
créati créativité des individus un
exercice qui n'est pas facile pour tout
le monde mais nous croyons que ce
potentiel est en chacun d'entre nous
même si parfois il est enfoui sous une
grande couche
de résignation de déception de peur
accumulée lors de différentes
expériences professionnelles mettre en
place ce type de mécanique nécessitent
les deux mêmes valeurs que pour la
monnaie la confiance et l'équité on doit
avoir confiance en les autres savoir que
même s'ils se trompent ils apprendront
et s'amélioreront que s'ils ont adhéré à
ce but commun ils sauront faire ce qui
doit l'être qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
deux carottes et encore moins de bâton
mais que la motivation elle peut venir
d'ailleurs de quelque chose de plus
profond en nous qui nous appellent à
contribuer au bien commun et pour que
cette confiance puisse s'établir et bien
il faut qu'elles puissent pousser sur un
terreau équitable alors je parle pas de
salaire mais déjà d'avoir les mêmes
règles pour tous le même accès aux
informations pour chacun par deux jeux
de pouvoir mais au contraire une
autorité clairement établie et distribué
entre tous
aujourd'hui il existe de nombreux
exemples inspirants de telles
organisations et des outils pour les
mettre en place dans le projet du
farinet eh bien il nous a semblé
incontournable aujourd'hui si nous
voulions réellement impacté la société
de mettre en place un système de gestion
démocratique et par démocratique
j'entends que chacun puisse être
entendue et voir ses besoins considérée
c'est ainsi que nous espérons semer les
graines qui permettront à nos sociétés
de reconsidérer leur façon aux devoirs
l'argent et les modèles d'organisation
pour que demain vos projets puissent
émerger dans un contexte favorable à la
durabilité et à la durabilité et à la
collaboration
merci
[Applaudissements]